une centaine d'organismes à
Montréal. Voici ce que ça donne.
- Madame Vézina,jojojour.
- Bonjour.
- Merci de nous recevoir
dans votre entrepôt.
Montréal.
- Une grosse journée
aujourd'hui.
CHANTAL VÉZINA, directrice
générale, Moisson Montréal
- C'uuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuùe
la guignolée des médias,
en effet.
- Bon, est-ce que vous croisez
les doigts ou vous êtes à peu
près sûre du résultat?sosososos?
- Écoutez, on peut présumer
de rien,onononon est certain que
les québécois sont généreux.
C'est sûr qu'il y a des défis,
d'inflation beaucoup
dans les médias, on peut pas
l'ignorer, mais on incitenenener
à la hauteur de leurs besoins,
de leur capacité.
- Vous dites : les québécois
les besoins ont jamais été
auss là là là là là. Vous le se.
Vous, vous êtes nouvelle ici,
c'
une nouvelle vision. Vous
z z z z z depuis quelques mois..
- Oui, tout à fait.
- Les besoins  q q q q q q q q s
vertigineux ici. C'est ce qui
m'a le plus surpris en arrivant
ici, définitivement.
Toute lntntntntntntntntntntntn,
elle ressort. Alors, on n'est
pas en mesure d'avoir
de l'inventaire à plus finir.
C'
de la marchandise se fait
très rapidement.
- Qu'est-ce qu'on voit là?
Qu'est-ce qu'ils font ça?
- Bien tout d'abord, c'est
des... de la marchandise q
reçoit beaucoup des marchands,
des épiceries, entre autres,
On classe la marchandise
parce lelelelelele, on reçoit
des boissons gazeuses,
on les met de côté, on reçoit de
des produits d'hygiène
les met de côté. Et les boîtes,,
c'est de la nourri
uniquement qui va là-dedans.
mis à part. Alo
ces boîtes-là vont être
préparées et ensuite vont êtr
C'est un peu comme des boîtesss
adorent ça parce que y a plein
de choses à l'intériesisisisisis
organismes dans l'écosystème,
dans la... prenons la grande
région de Montréal, est-ce
qu'ils vont utututututututututut
300 organismes sur l'île
de Montréal, on...
- C'est énorme!
- tetetetetetetetetetetetetetet.
Est-ce qu'ils vont en recevoir
assez? Je vais être honnête
avec vous, non. Les besoins sont
qu'on comble quand même une trè.
Et puis ça leur permet de faire
en fait. Ce qu'on fait commetran
d'aller chercher des denrées
- C'est intéressant parce que
vous venez d'arriver, il y a
quelques mois, puis vous suiviez
comme tout le monde, puis on
le répète : les besoins sont
énormes. On dirait que, là,
ça vous a même surprise.
- Mais tout à fait. Tout à fait.
Je veux dire, rentrer dans
d'ici, c'est plus de 100 000s s,
de voir qu'il y a autant
de capacités d'entreposage etal.
La clientèle change, hein, aussi
au niveau de l'aide alimentaire.
Il y avait une certaine
clientèle qui en avait besoin
tout le monde qui pourrait
en avoir besoin demain matin.
Donc, ça... la demande explose
à cause de ça aussi.
- Les 300 organismes,
vous rappellent, puis vous êtes
obligé de leur dire no
Est-ce que ça vous a...
ça vous a pas encore...
- Bien oui... bien
ça nous arrive. Ça nous arrive,
mais on essa.........
J'ai une équipe de trois
personnes à temps complet
qui fonttetetetetetetetetetetet,
qui font aussi les contacts
avec
On a quand même sept camions
qui roulent six jours
même une infrastructure, ici,
derniers mois pour, justement,
aller chercher le maxi...
on travaille en collaborat
avec d'autres Moissons aussi.
Mais ici, c'est 58 personnes
qui travaillent à temps complet,
en plus de bénévoles, pour fai
en sorte qu'il y ait de
la marchandise qui rentre,
aussi.
- Vous, vous provenez du monde
Costco, entre autes, vousezezez.
Est-ce que les grands
détaillants pourraient?
- Bien écoutez, je pense...- - t
pour vous.
- Moi, je vous d
ce que je perçois jusqu'à
maintenant, les gens font
vraiment leur part. Je dis pasds
je pense que tous les ma
de la chaîne sont assez bien
sollicités, mais il faut qu'on
dans notre travail, d'être plus
créatif, peut-ê
innovant, puis de travailler
davantage ensemble pour
- Alors toute la journée,
ça va
- Oui, ici, c'est notre
empl
les organismes viennent.
l l l l l l l l l l le...
comme on dit, le direct.
précommande, donc les organismes
peuvent...
- Le chaînon qu'on  f f f f f f.
- Les centres co
- Exactement.
- Donc, les ce l l l l l l l l e
puis empor
- Oui. Il y a un système
de prénsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsns
produits selon les inventaires
quonononononononononononon les
prépare, ces commandes-là,
pour accélérer le processus ç ç.
Et une fois qu'ils ont...dedede,
ils peuvent se promener.
Il y a des emplacementseseseses,
les fruits et légumes.uvuvuvuvur
puis bonifier leur commande.
- Quand les gens vous
beaucoup cette question-là,
est-ce qu'on
de l'argent ou des denrées
qu'on a chez nous?
- Écoutez, les besoins sont là.
Fadededededededededededededeux!
On va prendre les deux!
On va prendre les deux.
façon de donner des denrées
dans le sens que c'est sûr
que si les gens veulent faire
les porter ici, dans le cadre
de la Guignolée, on est
quand même 3 organisations
Ou encore il y a les Maxi et
Provigo où on peut aller porter
des denrées. Fait que ça,
pour nous, d'aller les chercher.
- Et ça va... c'est important
de le dire, ça finit pas
la Guignolée!a a a a a a a a a ?
- Non. C'est juste qu'à la fin
du mois de décmbmbmbmbmbmbmbmbm,
on sensibilise les gensr r r r à
de leur capacité, mais aussi
le site de la Guignolée reçoit
C'est un site qui est actif.
c'est 12 mois par année.
- Vous aimez ça? Vous arrivez...
- Ah! bien sûr!r r r r r r r r s
années à Moisson Montréal?
- Oui.
- Oui, moi, pour moi,adadadadad.
- Vous vous sentez utile.
- Bien, c'est un c
C'est une équipe formidable icit
dédiés à la cause puis
à la inininininininininininininm
par jour qui viennent ici.
Il y a des gens qui viennent
chaque jour depuis plusieurs
stststststststststststststststs.
Fait que c'est un... c'est un...
c'est un privilège pour
une gestionnaire de gérerbebebe!
Ça fait du bien, entend
- Bien, merci à vous!
- Merci! Au revoir